Drake and the rock give back you asked  me to come up here 11-year old heart  patient Sophia Sanchez got an amazing  birthday surprise when Drake showed up  to visit her in the hospital I didn't  talk for him as a fake look he came to  surprise me just for you and it gets  better  yesterday Sophia had her much-needed  heart transplant surgery meanwhile the  rock proved he's a hero in real life I'm  so sorry to hear about your sister and  your mom  I'm sending you so much love and light  Angela Pizarro posted this pic of his  mother after losing her and his sister  in a tragic car crash his wish a video  tribute from the star for his mom's  funeral imagine his shock when the rock  answered the call if your mom could see  me now which I'm sure she can I just  want to thank her for for all the love  and being such a big fan so stay strong  [Music]  you  [Music]